cet exemple n'est qu'un n'en est qu'un
parmi tant d'autres qui montrent que la
décision d'irre sa vie habilité qui a
été prise la semaine dernière et
contraire à tout à tous les usages de
notre assemblée en procédant ainsi vous
avez ouvert une voie dangereuse celle de
l'arbitraire oui nous voterons cette
motion censure pour faire tomber ce
gouvernement et pour que Madame borne
prenne sa petite valise et quitte sa
fonction parce que très clairement elle
a dépassé les bornes nous n'avons pas
confiance en gouvernement et tous les
députés qui rejettent cette confiance
doivent pouvoir voter une motion de
censure après le vote non mais ça ne
vaut pas alliance c'est ça qu'il faut
comprendre ce n'est pas une histoire
d'alliance ce qui se joue aujourd'hui
avec cette notion de censure c'est la
possibilité de mettre un terme au
discrédit que le gouvernement jette sur
l'Assemblée nationale entre résignation
et nécessité résignation parce que c'est
le bout d'un processus dans lequel on
s'est fait bananer à chaque fois et en
même temps il faut marquer le coup
merci Madame la président travaux de
montrer une nouvelle fois par cette
notion de censure que nous sommes bel et
bien dans une démocratie parlementaire
où le gouvernement est responsable
devant le Parlement qui peut à tout
moment tenter de le renverser non mais
la réforme des retraites elle sera pas
abrogée il faut continuer à l'expliquer
mais il faut continuer à l'accompagner
le fait qu'il y en ait eu 17 ans un an
et quand même un signal de du fait que
ce gouvernement tôt ou tard tombera
merci
de prouver une fois encore que notre
Constitution trouve grâce à vos yeux et
que vous ne resignez pas à faire usage
de son article 49 alinéa 2 mais est-ce
que vous pouvez s'il vous plaît vous
taire et écouter la première ministre
vous ne l'interromps vous ne cessez de
l'interrompre monsieur Boyard monsieur
Boyard je vous demande de vous taire
[Applaudissements]
monsieur Boyard monsieur Boyard je vous
rappelle alors et deux heures plus tard
pas de surprise donc la majorité requise
n'étant pas atteinte la motion de
censure n'est pas adoptée
monsieur Boyard
je prononce à votre rencontre un rappel
à lampe avec inscription au
procès-verbal
je vous prie de vous taire et de
respecter cet assemblée la première
ministre une enquête préliminaire a été
ouverte le 2 juin sur le financement de
campagne du micro partie du ministre de
l'économie Bruno Le Maire nous venons de
la prendre en cause des dettes non
payées à des prestataires qui pourraient
de se fait être assimilé à des dons
illégaux le micro parti avec BLM aurait
récolté 2 millions d'euros pour la
primaire de la droite de 2016 Silvio
Berlusconi est mort
Francesco fait le toi moi je n'y arrive
pas
je te comprends
des Italiens en nombre pour lui rendre
hommage devant l'hôpital Sandra féer de
Milan où il était soigné pour une
leucémie grâce à lui l'Italie a pris
qu'elle ne devait jamais se laisser
imposer des limites où se sentir vaincu
terriblement amaigri agar mais tous les
quatre envies voici la première vidéo de
la rencontre des petits miraculés avec
leur sauveteurs ils ont passé 40 jours à
manger de la farine puis des fruits de
la forêt
les enfants doivent froid leur premier
mot au sauveteur on a très faim maman
est morte déjà les proches s'inquiètent
de voir la fratrie séparée à sa sortie
de l'hôpital les quatre enfants sont nés
de deux paires différents et il y a un
risque que les deux plus grandes soient
placées par les services sociaux un
nouveau traumatisme qui pourrait bien
continuer d'émouvoir le pays